when you are trying to build a brand in
the tech space there's really two things
you should take a look at first and
probably most important think about
what's going on in the market around you
what are those market transitions
where's the innovation coming from
regardless of the place that you sit ii
probably just as important is one of the
problems that your customers are trying
to solve because if you can match up the
problems they're trying to solve and
your understanding of the market you can
really create some powerful innovation
and a really powerful brand strategy
that's in support of your company
strategy
the best way to get to know your
customers is to simply spend time with
them
I always find it amazing at how little
time marketeers
or even business leaders truly spend
with the customer not the buyer perhaps
or the the CXO who's doing the buying or
but really the people who are using your
products by spending time with your
customer either going on into their
offices or talking to them live and
understanding exactly how they're
interacting with your solution that is
the best customer data that you can get
and then you can really create a
strategy that will go after solving the
most important problems
the idea of partnerships is not a new
one but what I am seeing today are more
brands coming together to create a
multiplier effect so if you bring two
powerful brands together and ensuring
that each of the purpose of those brands
can intersect in some form or fashion
you're gonna get so much more and so
when you're trying to invest money in
building a brand or telling a corporate
story partnering with another company
who has a similar connection can really
extend your reach which is very powerful
increase the tonality make it more
positive than negative and make you that
much more relevant to a bigger audience
that is some of the really exciting
things that we're seeing in the world of
marketing today and that when it happens
digitally or online where you can really
follow the customers that's when you
really get some impact